so guys it's lovely to have you here on
flicks in the city today Judas and Harry
of course we're here to start talking
about your holiday singalong which we're
taking all around the show aren't you
starting off in London this weekend so
tell me what can we expect you can
expect reverence but mostly irreverence
because I think III think we all get so
overwhelmed by the Christmas season I
certainly do that's the reason I started
is because I've gone to be with Harry
my beloved here in America and I was so
fed up with all the perfect weather and
how beautiful it all was at the beach
and so I decided that I needed to remind
myself of the awfulness of Christmas you
know just like you know terrible weather
gray sadness fireplaces no light after
3:30 so I mean I just it was it was that
thing of nearly that's why we love our
Christmases so we started this thing and
and it's basically amazing musicians
great company around the piano it's old
school it's because I'm basically Welsh
in my deepest heart you see if you're
actually Welsh and every other party
about the other part my hope is as well
and so I and and depressed because of it
as we both know so yeah I so it's up
around the piano harmonizing it sounds
so corny but actually it's brilliant
it's why people like rock choir well all
these things where people are now
singing together people now realize it
actually isn't that something that we've
been doing forever
isn't there a reason we all love singing
together even if we can't sing and and
this is exactly what we describe it as
the antidote to Christmas but it's like
a kickoff bit early this year in London
but and it's always a group of our
musical and comedy friends in whatever
whichever City we do the show so in
London it's Maureen Lipman with whom
I've just been touring in a play Rob
Brydon whose comedy and music wrapped up
and do one ridiculous person Barry from
Watford we're singing it well we're
singing your book boy under some Barry
from what probably their Alice Russell
the great UK
soeul songstress jake'd Acworth great
jazz singer her husband the ridiculously
talented Charlie wood from Memphis
Tennessee Kiki Dee he's coming on to do
some incredible arm being a Christmas
time which we love to have and then we
have a bit of classical with this
wonderful friend of mine and classical
cellist and go remarkable woman
Gabriella swallow who's just gonna be
that cross-section Danny Thompson the
legendary bass player is playing with us
so it's a it's a great show and then
after all that everybody does one or two
numbers seems to the holidays I do a
song by the American singer-songwriter
chill so Byul it speaks to the the unity
that we all feel at this time of year
which is called Jesus was a dreidel
spinner I'm scared you're gonna put it
away from me so the I know it's just
because I can't stop talking that's the
problem I know we're married hey what
can we do so um but we the point was of
course it's sort of trying we're trying
not to make this this this isn't like a
going to church
this isn't ain't Christmas this is a
religious situation this this is just
that great sense of fun and beautiful
music but literally it started in our
house it was a fun thing then we got
asked to do it in Walt Disney Concert
Hall and it because they'd heard about
the this incredible party and the next
thing it having a Katrina had happened
and so it began as a money raiser in the
first place was in a Walt Disney Concert
Hall in LA and now we're doing it and
about was this five or six cities you
can name Mary I will in a moment but
this is a benefit in this particular one
for the Philippine typhoon relief relief
fund of the International Red Cross and
then as we go across America will be
doing New York at Brooklyn Museum of
Music Brooklyn Academy of Music December
7th Philadelphia the is the 8th at the
World Cafe live in Hollywood understand
on December 14th that has got a cast of
people that is just shocking to me how
amazing it will be a forget about it
sold out so forget about it forget about
LA
then we go to Chicago space Evanston
Illinois this beautiful club called
space in Evanston on the 19th and then
we finish up as we normally do within
New Orleans with two shows at the Ogden
Museum on the 21st and 22nd and as I say
in each city it's different players
different people that are our friends in
each city but the point I was going to
make is after the interval all that
happens before the interval at the
interval Judith recommends that the
audience go get liquored up and then she
sort of brow beats them into singing
Christmas carols and gives them crap
prizes complete evening to be fair to be
fair oh yeah but it is true but to be
fair I or should I say our assistant
finds crap presents all year long for me
and it I've devised a way of making
people misbehave in the best imaginable
way which is by doing the 12 days of
Christmas as a well basically you're
competing so I divide the audience up
into 12 sections and you have to mime as
you're singing it and each of the days
and the more gratuitous and lewd it gets
the more I like it
obviously eight maids a-milking is a big
one I can't even tell you what people do
to each other but the price and the
prizes are just absolutely crap awful
and I take that spot as a joy well
that's one part of Christmas isn't it
you know when you open something and
it's really really not what you wanted
those awful presents it's interesting
presence because you also mentioned and
you touched on new behaviors so you went
to London you probably people lewd
behavior and prizes I have wondered what
Reverend Lovejoy might say about that
Harry if he came across that situation
where people being promised lewd
presents at Christmas well they're
promised crap as I understand that crap
presents for lewd behavior I think lewd
presents for crap behavior would be an
interesting switch on that idea and we
might have that of the church social now
and then I'll have to look into that now
you touched on some of the songs that
you sing at the event what what are your
favorite moments of the evenings I do
love to see how I do Jesus was a dreidel
spinner for obvious reasons
and I personally like doing Christmas
was the devil that spinal tap classic
with Harry as a jazz standard and I
think there are 12 days of Christmas
it's pretty much as insane an event as
it can get you can't believe what you're
watching I know people probably watching
this think I would like that guy once
said to us I would rather stab my own
eyes out that go to go to this evening
cuz it I'm sure it sounds frightening
dire and frightening but but it's huge
fun and I should say Judith is
emphasizing the fun part of it but she
wrote a beautiful song called the
dancing tree which is about her learning
to decorate the tree when she was a
child and it's a very moving beautiful
song and that sort of ends up act1 so
they're moving some serum as well as the
laughter so we Revere back and forth
between the two I think that's that's
sort of what makes it it never gets
goopy but it never gets totally out of
control it's that thing where it's
exactly what Christmas is it's like that
I find Christmas to be so bittersweet I
want it to be as we all do brilliant the
expectations are so high it's so moving
to me because of my childhood memories
of it it's something when I see all the
fairy lights and all the decorations I
do literally tear up and at the same
time I find it so hard and and I think
people struggle at this time of the year
they really really do and I think what
everybody needs is a good bit of release
and singing and getting to feel but
getting to laughs - two biggest some two
biggest things I think singing and
laughing I mean that's really it
I know inking oh yeah don't forget that
three big things now what do you guys
enjoy most about working together when
you're in that stage we argue much less
than when we're in real life there's so
much more on the same wavelength when
we're working together then when we have
to actually put up with each other in a
normal life in the kitchen yeah um for
example Borja or anyway yeah well Harry
and I gets on exceedingly well when we
work together and people are always
saying you know the usual
things like guys are great you know you
must be laughing 24 hours a day the
reaction is like I look about as you
know fact up as a human being can affect
you can say that zone so it's it we love
to work and we love to laugh when we
love music and Harry's a great musician
as well as we him incredible and Judith
you know when the famous
Doyen of online journalism at Arianna
Huffington met Judith first okay just a
little understanding she's this
incredible green lady and and Arianna
forgive us for this boat cuz cuz cuz we
love you so much well we've since then
had Ariana offs where we try and see who
can do her voice the best so this was
the line she said killed it have you
always been this funny I was there
something that happened after your man
Hattie so if those of you who have had
the good fortune of seeing what's with
honey poopoo on YouTube may have seen
Judith's funny side where she depicts a
not toothless tooth full to be fair wine
disease yeah white white trash mama of a
teen of a sub teen beauty queen with a
problem that she's and as the mother
says she's got all the pageant knowledge
in her brain but not the toilet
knowledge alone page knowledge but not
at all of knowledge where did that idea
come from because that's not at all like
anything in reality I because Harry is
so superior to me in so many ways
they're mostly intelligence he and and
the read the knowledge you know you're
so above me in the knowledge
and I feel like I'm like that some the
Lyoness that brings home the kill for
the you know for the male he just lies
there and sort of like beautiful and he
and so he so I feel like I'm always
showing Harry utter wretched terrible
stuff that I can that I find a turn this
the whole point is I find the worst
stuff I can find so you know he brought
me American pageant queen pageant queens
and you know the talent section of
pageants which I've never ever got over
in my entire life is so good of the
original you know like the Miss America
pageant's the state beauty pageants I
was getting all the state beauty
pageants for a while by satellite and I
would they would have these ridiculous
talent competitions that were egregious
is just is to complement them to highly
wearing her talent was she wore red
leather had to for everything in and
water it was all Fringe and red leather
and then she played flight of the
bumblebee n--'s big flight of the
bumblebees on the glockenspiel and and
that you know that just makes you go but
the singing is the one that we cherish
and I put up on on YouTube as a matter
of fact is a woman called Missy Pitts
who was in her second try at Miss
Mississippi was singing as it was
described by her interlocutor the Barbra
Streisand 1970 style song the main event
and it's not a lot of notes in the song
she misses all of them it's pretty it's
pretty good is what it's a Missy is
watching we love you miss you love you
your family so Judas comes back with it
with honey boo boo it says you but you
got to see this what I sound so connects
you know which one is our lead boo boo
she comes with tiny bit look at this
so they're smugly and Harry just little
you know he is you know it's the follow
that's a Roman Empire base at the end
the to Buster to children said it just
can't get any worse can it and then we
thought no he can yes I can and that's
how it started
will there be anymore them anymore honey
boo-boo I hope so I mean before she gets
too old before she before if he rains it
in got two big foam suits you know big
amen so suits for marvelous man suits
made so I feel it'd be a real shame to
hang up hang up the fat suit hang up the
fat suit in the bad hair I mean I think
it'd be a crime yeah but I said earlier
there's nothing more wonderful than then
being an ish the sentencer I never it's
like the snow took you Americans knew
yeah there's nothing more wonderful than
being egregious and an awful person as a
character you know I'm it's why we love
ab fab it's why we love this kind of
characters I mean there's nothing funny
about nice people and cute love the
freaky people it's like these really
offensive egregious people there's the
end of my sentence I would say in
summation that there's a whole world
left to soil I love it well should we
continue talking before about the
holiday sing-along I wondered how you
would describe each other's style when
it comes to singing and performing on
stage
Harry is this incredible radio show
called the show that's been going for
nearly 30 years
coming Sunday correct and I would say
that his satirical songs is really what
he is and I mean after the comedian and
right animal recipe but as I always see
he was being as a satirist us and so
Christmastime how you it writes a brand
new song which is something about what's
going on in the world and can we spill
the beans
yeah do you know who Rob Ford is the
Mayor of Toronto
so I've written a very very I think very
pretty
tribute to Rob Ford called the Yuletide
snows of Toronto I don't know what
refers to no I have no idea these are
the snows that tickle your nose the
Yuletide snows of Toronto is the last
last that guy is a gift to the world
I've never seen a train wreck like this
this makes me so happy it's like every
day he's doing something appalling yeah
this week is a disappoint because he
hasn't been in the news yet but it's
only Wednesday exactly just kiss the
gift that keeps giving I mean this is
our Christmas personally so that's so I
expect Harry to do something
unbelievably small greatly satirical
very much tropical that is you know
that's part of to me part of the show
and and I am because I'm mistress
Christmas and I'm such a bossy Bears
there's bit of panto in me it's been
pants I'm hiding so I feel I knew it is
finite so he so I get to be bossy on
stage and Harry basically it's like our
marriage he get away just pick her on
stage and harry gets to basically look
at me in horror and the stuff that's
coming out my mouth but as a performer
you know Judith when she sings like
missing the Christmas song yes no that's
wrong
nice the way I did that and the dancing
tree of the aforementioned dancing tree
and she can make you weep she's a very
emotional not overly dramatic melon or
melon around by any stretch of the
imagination but just legitimately
soulful heartfelt singers so there is
that to to laugh so much because we're
really serious I mean it's obviously
nothing as shown itself in this in time
to do but we are at heart really serious
about what we do and very and quite
serious and probably you know dark
people and that's why Doug people yeah
slightly so what are people loved our
people know read our people have no
to live that so yeah that we are and I
think that's all that's why it's a
beautiful blend I didn't know she just
mentions 30th anniversary of the show
your radio show and you've also got
another anniversary coming up next year
haven't you for a little little thing
but I don't know if many people would
have heard I'll call spinal tap yeah I
won here is that the it may be coming
around to the 30th all I can say about
that is that if any band in the world
would get the chronology or the 30 fan a
30th anniversary wrong it might well be
spinal tap so they might not be right on
on the money with the celebration but
it'll be coming eventually I'm biased
but I died who was boss before I met you
it's just really a film I believe music
I thought you were gonna stop after ever
made yeah I was gonna I was gonna say
well in all fairness Citizen Kane Kane
in fairness you but no no I don't know
can we expect a reunion anytime you
think you guys would be getting better
well I think part you know that would be
we are reuniting under the banner of
Monty Python I think you've heard that
announcement so will be going up as
mighty Python and making a lot of money
that way like a Christmas show well
that's right we will
Michael Michael Chris and I will be will
be performing Christmas with the devil
acoustic acoustic stylee at the
Christmas show but yeah I think the
performing will be part of whatever we
do eventually at the whatever the 30th
anniversary church had to be because we
love to play we still love to play now
I'm wondered if we could hear from some
of your best known current just Simpsons
and what they might think of this
holiday sing-along that you're going to
be doing all over the States and the UK
well C Montgomery burns is appalled by
the idea because it involves the giving
of cash it's not not something I'm used
to doing I take in cash it doesn't go
away I attracted I do not repeal it
I think I didn't find yours would be
overjoyed to see if I giving your
tribute to our Lord and Savior in your
own particular way you can do a little a
little lesson laughter you know a little
more of it okay you know do me a little
more the show on your knees this year
would be a good idea don't you think be
blessing and how do you think Kent
Brockman right report on me that's just
in comedy and music take the stage in
London and around the world this holiday
season and I for one will not be there
what Kent Brockman what the volume is
unbelievable isn't it it's just so vain
it is shocking
before we early television we couldn't
afford microphones we just yell out
enough saying get the picture and they'd
listen through the window and that's a
true story folks
Judy's as well as of course the
sing-along which you've got an album
coming out as well haven't you and
you've released a single recently to
tell me about that yes
I just uh I did a I did a duet with the
fabulous Julia Fordham who's a dear
friend of mine and we both event in
America as well as here and and we were
looking for something really scrumming
and yummy to do for Christmas because
she's always she's like the cool person
on Christmas show and for the first time
it's in oh gosh what eight years
she actually can't isn't gonna be
chewing with a saw at any of these shows
because she's doing her own run in
London and so we thought you know what
let's let's do that thing that we've
longed to do together which is to do it
together and we were thinking of doing
something in future and it's the white
Christmas let's make it a lovely another
good thing let's do it for the Red Cross
you know the International Red Cross
Philippines Relief Fund as you know the
the money's from the London show the
sing-along we're going to that
completely was it's good to be going
from the American shows and also to the
new musicians clinic of New Orleans but
but it was again you don't want to be
sickly sweet as you've probably noticed
if you saw the video I just thought you
know what and we agreed it's such a
gorgeous song it makes
so when I have a glass of red wine you
know playing to Sherry and just for
rugged affronted and open fire blazing
and then we thought wouldn't it be
fantastic if we actually did have a bit
of a laugh of our own expense one must
so we asked the fantastic Jennifer
Coolidge who is a goddess come on she
says there's no sexier woman who can be
so overtly sexy and yes so extreme and
subtle in her ways but you know she's so
much larger than life it's incredible so
it's funny boys would say I'm sorry
that's all I meant by larger than life
or even incredible and then she is she's
a goddess of a comedian she really
buddies so she came in and ended a cameo
at the in our video which i think is
absolutely kind of a trouser soaking
moment for me I'm not going to give away
anything that goes on but it all these
best things are available as and you can
get that for free and the song is on
iTunes my own project that's coming out
next year I'm very very excited about
because it's been a dream of mine for
since I you know kit here in London
growing up and listening to people who
influenced me is as a singer-songwriter
like your James Taylor's and your Carole
King's there's more than what you have
sailing you James Taylor's you Carole
King's yes here's a couple of Carole
King's right over hey Kings just getting
really diva meaning I won't just create
my line that so anyway so yes I was
listening to the individuals not the
group of each people so and I love the
musician so much I just thought yeah
that vibe that sound was have such an
influence upon me and then because of
the light went on in my you know over my
head and I just thought why why aren't I
actually recording with those guys I've
been doing this thing and having this
after all this time so basically I went
back to the source and I invited some of
the original members of the James
Shannon Carole King's band which is Russ
Kunkel and Leland Sklar and
cocktail and we've made quite I think
amazing I'm very proud of it record and
we will be coming every year to to
London and we will be touring in
throughout America and we're doing some
private listening things starting in
February March and then we'll be on on
the road and I and I feel like it's a
it's a real dream come true working with
men like that and I've never felt so
happy in the studio and it's sort of
what a joy going on the road with those
guys you know busy street for me
absolutely yeah and tough day are you
looking forward to seeing to you this on
the stage of those guys I am so looking
forward to it because Judas is never
happier than on stage yeah never happier
than when she's on stage performing and
especially with these guys I mean we've
known Lee and Lee has worked with me and
a couple of my little comedy music tours
and I saw I know from personal
experience what a joy it is to turn
around and see not only to hear him
giving you that that musical foundation
but to turn around and see that presence
on stage he's had been nificent he
presents on stage and he makes you feel
so calm and so cool and so wonderful as
always I envy her from being in blue
lace it's a you know when when you hear
music and it's influenced you as a kid
and then you're playing and recording
your songs and you're hearing that sound
that feeling on you your music it's
really quite something
I mean how sort of I do get a little
emotional about it but I think these are
amazing people there are amazing
musicians and man I really feel
incredibly fortunate and lucky to be
working but I can see you can have an
incredible experience definitely yeah I
can't wait to get on the road with him I
can't wait and hurry what's next for you
I did a television series that's just
going out on Sky Arts here in England
and in the entire united kingdom unless
Scotland goes away called Nixon's the
one which will be going out early next
year sort of a you know Judas talking
about dream projects as have been a
dream
to mind to take sort of the goofiest
craziest moments from the Nixon White
House tapes he was one of the most
bizarre persons ever to occupy high
office in the world since probably one
of the Caesars and he's done us the huge
favor of tape recording almost his every
waking under ins so we can plow through
it for to see just how interesting he
was and so my partners and I have called
the transcripts for the really most
bizarre funniest strangest moments this
has nothing to do with politics or
Watergate or Vietnam it's not a history
show it's a comedy show but it's all
verbatim and a wonderful cast of people
play all of the henchmen and SH women
and then we've shot it as if he had
hidden not only microphones but cameras
all around the white the Oval Office so
it looks like stuff you were never
supposed to see and that so I'm very
proud of that we go out with that in
January and then this play that I've
been in with Maureen Lipman and John
boat called Daytona written by Oliver
cotton the actor Oliver cotton
wonderful play may in fact be coming to
the West End so fingers crossed what was
the most mind-boggling thing you found
about Nixon when you were combing
through those tapes commotion there were
some doozies that came up there you know
he was quite a connect you medical in
his hatreds
you're always amazed one knows a few of
his prejudices but it just he just was
so full of this burning these burning
resentments and hatreds and they just
sprayed all over the place but I think
the thing that and it's in the first
episode of the series that one keeps
going back to is the strangeness of his
relationship with a man who's still
alive for God's sake Henry Kissinger
sort of a famous icon of depending on
how you see it either international
strategy or war crime but both very
smart people both really fascinated with
power both feel like they're using the
other Nixon not really fond of Jews
Henry one of the few truths he allows in
his cabin and Nixon notably full of
contempt for people from Harvard Henry's
mr. Harvard
I saw I was at the the hundredth
anniversary of the Nixon's birth in
front of my sneak me into the
celebration in Washington earlier this
year and Kissinger is there 89 years old
gives a speech and of course the thrust
of his speeches Nixon was great because
he really let me run things and it's
just that's it then and the two of them
you know it's like two black widows
widow spiders circling each other at all
times it's a wonderful thing to watch
and through words they wait to look 40
from both of you I was torn
I know it's I'm hoping to its world
domination I I feel so good because like
for the longest time I was like you know
you did so many things that that you
could do spit you know in in Britain as
well but the kind of people that the
sense of the comedic sense here as well
I was thought that I would really fit in
well sooner so I'm thrilled that that
you got to do the Nixon I'm not sure
about couse you might have been done it
this way I don't actually know yeah I
always thought that if we tried to do it
in America I'd be having these meetings
with people who were saying no I I know
he doesn't like black people but does he
have to hate Jews too you know this is
the real stuff right it now
so we god bless the sky people they let
us do it and these are people actually
in the sky they I don't know how they
live up there they've solved the gravity
the whole gravity problem but they let
us do the show exactly as we intend and
and so you know that's rare that's
rarely from from first thought to last
look at the tape he it's everything as
as was intended so so it's exciting it's
you know the like the Nixon project and
then hopefully do it de Taylor will get
it go into the West End and then and
then my well my record by the way is
called Evan flow I've got to mention
that Evan flow they met comes out
roll and then from that point onward who
knows who knows but it will be busy busy
busy until next year's sing-along comes
and bites again all we know it will be
sitting with you again going what
happened to you guys in loving talking
to you enjoy the sing-alongs here and in
the state's about short every will be
there having a fabulous time thank you
so much for having us next time
you